twice a week I Drive from my home near
Tijuana Mexico over the US border to my
office in San Diego the stark contrasts
between the poverty and desperation on
one side of the border and the
conspicuous wealth on the other always
feels jarring but what's makes this
contrast feel even starker is when I
pass by the building that those of us
who work on the border on affectionately
referred to as the black hole the black
hole is the Customs and Border
Protection or CBP facility at the San
Ysidro Port of Entry right next to a
luxury outlet mall it's also where at
any one time there's likely 800
immigrants locked in freezing filthy
concrete cells below the building up top
shopping bags and frappuccinos
downstairs the reality of the u.s.
immigration system and it's where one
day in September of 2018
I found myself trying to reach Ana a
woman who CBP had recently separated
from her seven-year-old son I'm an
immigration attorney and the policy and
litigation director of al otro lado a
bi-national nonprofit helping immigrants
on both sides of the us-mexico border
we'd met ana several weeks earlier at
our Tijuana office where she explained
that she feared she and her son would be
killed in Mexico so we prepared her for
the process of turning herself over to
CBP to ask for asylum
a few days after she'd gone to the port
of entry to ask for help we received a
frantic phone call from her family
members in the United States telling us
that CBP officials had taken Ana son
from her now not that this should matter
but I knew that Ana's son had special
needs and once again this news filled me
with a sense of panic and foreboding
that has unfortunately become a hallmark
of my daily work I had a signed
authorization to act as Ana's attorney
so I rushed over to the port of entry to
see if I could speak with my client not
only with CBP officials not let me speak
to Ana
but they wouldn't even tell me if she
was there I went from supervisor to
supervisor begging to submit evidence of
Anna's son special needs but no one
would even talk to me about the case it
felt surreal to watch the shopper
strolling idly by what felt like a
life-and-death situation
after several hours of being stonewalled
by CBP I left several days later I found
an his son in the foster care system but
I didn't know what happened to Ana until
over a week later when she turned up at
a detention camp a few miles east now
Ana didn't have a criminal record and
she followed the law when asking for
asylum still immigration officials held
her for three more months until we could
win her release and help her reunify
with her son Ana's story is not the only
story I could tell you there's Mateo an
18 month old boy who was ripped from his
father's arms and sent to a government
shelter thousands of miles away where
they failed to properly bathe him for
months
there's Amadou an unaccompanied African
child who was held with adults for 28
days and CBP's horrific facilities most
disturbingly there's Maria a pregnant
refugee who begged for medical attention
for eight hours before she miscarried in
CBP custody
CBP officials held her for three more
weeks before they sent her back to
Mexico where she's being forced to wait
months for an asylum hearing in the
United States
seeing these horrors day in and day out
has changed me I used to be fun at
parties but now I inevitably find myself
telling people about how our government
tortures refugees at the border and in
the detention camps now people try to
change the subject and congratulate me
for the great work I'm doing and helping
people like Ana but I don't know how to
make them understand that unless they
start fighting harder than they ever
thought possible we don't know which of
us will be the next to suffer Ana's fate
Trump's mass separations of refugee
families at the southern border shocked
the conscience of the world and welcome
any to the cruelties of the u.s.
immigration system it seems like today
more people than ever are involved in
the fight for immigrant rights but
unfortunately the situation is just not
getting better
thousands protested to end family
separations but the government is still
separating families more than 900
children have been taken from their
parents since June of 2018 thousands
more refugees have been taken from their
grandparents
wings and other family members at the
border since 2017 at least two dozen
people have died in immigration custody
and more will die including children now
we lawyers can and will keep filing
lawsuits to stop the government from
brutalizing our clients but we can't
keep tinkering around the edges of the
law if we want migrants to be treated
humanely this administration would have
you believe that we have to separate
families and we have to detain children
because it will stop more refugees from
coming to our borders but we know that
this isn't true
in fact in 2019 the number of
apprehensions that our southern border
have actually gone up and we tell people
every day at the border if you seek
asylum in the United States
you risk family separation and you risk
being detained indefinitely but for many
of them the alternative is even worse
people seek refuge in the United States
for a lot of different reasons in
Tijuana
we've met refugees from over 50
countries speaking 14 different
languages we meet LGBT migrants from all
over the world who've never been in a
country in which they feel safe we meet
women from all over the world
whose own governments refuse to protect
them from brutal domestic violence or
oppressive social norms of course we
meet Central American families who are
fleeing gang violence but we also meet
Russian dissidents Venezuelan activists
Christians from China Muslims from China
and thousands and thousands of other
refugees fleeing all types of
persecution and torture now a lot of
these people would qualify as refugees
under the international legal definition
the Refugee Convention was created after
World War Two to give protection to
people fleeing persecution based on
their race religion nationality
political opinion or membership in a
particular social group but even those
who would be refugees under the
International definition are not going
to win asylum in the United States and
that's because since 2017 the US
Attorneys General have made sweeping
changes to asylum law to make sure that
less people qualify for protection in
the United States now these laws are
mostly aimed at Central
Americans and keeping them out of the
country but they affect other types of
refugees as well the result is that the
us frequently Deportes refugees to their
persecution and death the u.s. is also
using detention to try to deter refugees
and make it harder for them to win their
cases
today there are over 55,000 immigrants
detained in the United States many in
remote detention facilities far from any
type of legal help and this is very
important because it's civil and not
criminal detention there is no public
defender system
so most detained immigrants are not
going to have an attorney to help them
with their cases an immigrant who has an
attorney is up to ten times more likely
to win their case than one who doesn't
and as you've seen I hate to be the
bearer of bad news but the situation is
even worse for refugee families today
than it was during family separation
since January of 2019
the US has implemented a policy that's
forced over 40,000 refugees to wait in
Mexico for asylum hearings in the United
States these refugees many of whom are
families are trapped in some of the most
dangerous cities in the world where
they're being raped kidnapped and
extorted by criminal groups and if they
survive for long enough to make it to
their Asylum hearing less than 1% of
them are able to find an attorney to
help them with their cases the US
government will point to the lowest suit
of asylum approval rates to argue that
these people are not really refugees
when in fact US asylum law is an
obstacle course designed to make them
fail now not every migrant at the border
is a refugee I meet plenty of economic
migrants for example people who want to
go to the United States to work to pay
medical bills for a parent or school
fees for a child back home increasingly
I'm also meeting climate refugees in
particular I'm meeting a lot of
indigenous Central Americans who can no
longer sustain themselves by farming due
to catastrophic drought in the region we
know that today people are migrating
because of climate change and that more
will do so in the future
we simply don't have a legal system to
deal with this type of migration so it
would make sense as a start to expand
the refugee definition to include
climate refugees for example but those
of us in a position to advocate for
those changes are too busy suing our
governments to keep the meager legal
protections that refugees enjoy under
the current law and we are exhausted and
it's it's almost too late to help and we
know now that this isn't America's
problem alone from Australia's brutal
offshore detention camps to Italy's
criminalization of aid to migrants
drowning in the Mediterranean first
world countries have gone to deadly
lengths to keep refugees from reaching
our shores but they've done more than
restrict the refugee definition they've
created parallel fascist style legal
systems in which migrants have none of
the rights that form the basis of a
democracy
the alleged foundation of the countries
in which they're seeking refuge history
shows us that the first group to be
vilified and stripped of their rights is
rarely the last and many Americans and
Europeans seem to accept an opaque and
unjust legal system for non-citizens
because they think they are immune but
eventually these authoritarian ideals
bleed over and affect citizens as well I
learned this firsthand when the US
government placed me on an illegal watch
list for my work helping immigrants at
the border one day in January of 2019 I
was leaving my office in San Diego and
crossing the border to go back to my
home in Mexico Mexican officials
although they had given me a valid visa
stopped me and told me that I couldn't
enter the country because a foreign
government had placed a travel alert on
my passport designating me as a national
security risk I was detained and
interrogated in a filthy room for hours
I begged the Mexican officials to let me
go back to Mexico and pick up my son who
was only 10 months old at the time but
they refused and instead they turned me
over to CBP officials or I was forced
back into the United States it took me
weeks to get another visa so that I
could go back to Mexico and I went back
to the border visa in hand but again I
was detained and interrogated because
there were still a traveler in my
passport shortly after leaked internal
CBP documents confirmed that my own
government had been complicit in issuing
this traveler against me and since then
I haven't traveled to any other
countries because I'm afraid I'll be
detained and deported from those
countries as well these travel
restrictions detentions and separation
from my infant son are things I never
thought I would experience as a US
citizen but I'm far from the only person
being criminalized for helping
immigrants the US and other countries
have made it a crime to save lives and
those of us who are simply trying to do
our jobs are being forced to choose
between our humanity and our freedom and
the thing that makes me so desperate is
that all of you are facing the same
choice but you don't understand it yet
I know there are good people out there I
saw thousands of you in the streets
protesting family separation and that
largely helped bring about an end to the
official policy but we know that the
government is still separating children
and things are actually getting worse
today the US government is fighting for
the right to detain refugee children
indefinitely in prison camps this isn't
over
we cannot allow ourselves to become numb
or look away those of us who are
citizens of countries whose policies
caused detention separation and deaths
need to very quickly decide which side
were on we need to demand that our laws
respect the inherent dignity of all
human beings especially refugees seeking
help at our borders but including
economic migrants and climate refugees
we need to demand that refugees get a
fair shot at seeking protection in our
countries by ensuring that they have
access to counsel and by creating
independent courts that are not subject
to the political whims of the president
I know it's overwhelming and I know this
sounds cliche but we need to call our
elected representatives and demand these
changes I know you've heard this before
but have you made the call we know these
calls make a difference the dystopian
immigration system is being built up in
first world
countries are a test of citizens to see
how far you're willing to let the
government go and taking away other
people's rights when you think it won't
happen to you but when you let the
government take people's children
without due process and detain people
indefinitely without access to counsel
you are failing the test what's
happening to immigrants now is a preview
of where we're all headed if we fail to
act thank you
[Applause]
[Music]